hey it's Justine and I will be at the
Apple event so I am so excited because
we are officially an iPhone season now I
mean we are this close make sure you
guys follow me on Twitter and Instagram
I just ian and subscribe to my youtube
channel so you guys mean all of the
updates as they happen as I said I will
be there but right now I'm not there yet
if you're watching this video after the
event has already happened hopefully I
will have a video up here shortly for
you recapping everything that was
announced but in the meantime let's talk
about some of the rumors some of the
things that we can expect it from the
announcements is obviously three new
iPhones the iPhone 11 Pro which is kind
of a new naming convention she's kind of
excited about actually the iPhone 11 in
the iPhone 11 are so judging by this
imitation by innovation only rules
people are assuming that these are going
to be the colors of the new iPhone 11
our we've got the purple and the green
here and of course we have the red the
yellow and the blue I'll put a link in
the description where I'm getting a lot
of information from it's on 95 Mac and
this is basically an article who's
talking about all the things that we can
expect
well the main focus is on v2 iPhone 11
here is they're talking about the camera
so the three lenses it doesn't be really
fun because it's gonna be great for
video because one of the things that I
love is having a wide-angle lens and
this time they're also doing an upgrade
to the front-facing camera again this is
all rumors I'm literally reading this
from a website where people are
predicting these things I don't actually
100% know I was mentioning how you're
taking photos at the same time this is
we called the smart frame as they're
saying here this feature will capture
the area around the framed area in
pictures of videos so it'll give you the
ability to kind of adjust the framing
which I love especially when I'm
shooting 4k video I'm always constantly
punching in just like this in my videos
even though I still do exported 4k I
know that that's degrading the quality
it still is my editing style which I
wish I was shooting an 8k as soon as 8k
is easier to shoot I will definitely be
doing it so if our facing camera this is
what I'm really excited about
it'll reportedly bump up the quality
from 7 megapixels to 12 and it'll go
from a 4 element to a 5 element lens and
it'll be capable of slo-mo videos which
I guess is not really
necessary because I don't typically
shoot front-facing slow-mo videos but
it's reporting that you'll be able to do
120 frames a second and here it is three
camera lenses they're also talking about
possibly making a matte version of the
iPhone much like they previously have in
the past one of the features that was
new in the Samsung phones is being able
to use your phone to charge something
else so that is something that it looks
like the next iPhone will have so you
can charge your air pods or anything
that is cheap Wireless compatible so the
5.8 inch iPhone battery will increase
between 20 and 25 percent and a 6.5 inch
between 10 to 15% any battery increase
and we'll definitely take it but I'll
tell you what it's gonna take a lot for
me to offer up my phone battery charge
for someone else is like it's gonna have
to be a life-threatening problem for me
to say sure you can have some of my
power hopefully they do good battery
charging cases out soon even with the
increased battery I just love this thing
I love it so much it looks like the
design will kind of stay the same
they're saying that the Apple logo
placement maybe move down just gonna
have like this massive square here of
lenses but the overall design kind of
stay the same
other than the option of having a matte
finish honestly still to this day this
the golda foam right here is my favorite
iPhone if to date it's also been rumored
that Apple will remove the iPhone
brandings in the back of this year's
model oh but how will I ever know that
my iPhone is an iPhone if my iPhone
doesn't say that it's an iPhone reports
is that the iPhone 11 pro will finally
drop the five watt charger and come with
the Apple USB C Charter and lightning to
USB C cable in the Box let's just make
it USB C don't give me a USB C charger
at all just change the iPhone USB C just
do it just rip the band-aid off just
make it super sticky and then just rip
it off we will all be excited about it I
always have
be excited I think all of the people
that are making accessories and stuff
probably wouldn't be excited but I mean
it's not it's not unlike you guys to do
it and I would definitely be supporting
it and that brings us to the Apple watch
which is something that I'm hopeful for
they're talking about adding sleep
tracking I don't think that they're
gonna release a series 5 Apple watch
this year but they're talking about here
is they know that Apple is planning to
introduce a ceramic and titanium models
of the Apple watch for years I had one
of larger watch faces and I have very
small wrists so when I did finally
switch to the smaller watch face my
entire life just got flipped upside down
especially when you're working out and
constantly being active like now with
this support loop I don't even know I'm
wearing a watch half the time except
when I take it off and realize that I
have quite the Apple watch tan line can
you guys see that I also have an
indentation also likely we'll get new
Apple watch bands through the fall
season I would really like a camo watch
band that'd be so perfect for fall and
perfect for me the Apple tag this is
much like the tile trackers that you
guys have seen me talk about before this
is gonna be pretty interesting this is
basically like a tag that you can put on
things and then locate them I will be
putting this on absolutely everything
and that is a promise because I'm always
losing stuff I'll put one on the dog I
will on I don't know like a water bottle
that I've set down in the house what's
great about tile is it still uses their
database of people who are using tile
and using Bluetooth if you lose an item
it's constantly pinging itself or
somebody else who has a child tracker or
a towel and abled on their phone with
this it's gonna be crazy because if this
is something that is integrated into iOS
you're gonna have a much better chance
of finding your lost item because pretty
much a lot of people have iPhones if you
haven't realized it so obviously we're
gonna be getting new iOS 13 iPad OS oh
my gosh TV OS I'm sure they're gonna be
talking a little bit more about their
paid services like the Apple RK that
they announced at WWDC which I'm really
excited about because I
playing iPhone games since I travel so
much like I'm always traveling with my
phone in my Nintendo's way I wish that I
could travel with my xbox but that
sometimes is not realistic but I almost
always have my phone with me actually I
do always have my phone with me that's
not like a maybe if that's a definite so
I'm definitely excited to see what they
announce with the Apple TV plus and I
think one of the things that a lot of
people have been talking about online is
how are they going to bundle these
features together so you're paying one
price and you get a bunch of different
services because right now I'm paying a
lot of money for a lot of things so I
would love it to pay just like one fee
and know that I'm getting all of these
things bundled in I'm also hoping that
they give us an update about what the
Mac Pros will be potentially releasing
because obviously that's something that
I'm really excited for there's been
rumors of a 16 inch macbook there's also
good rumors of Apple boggles Apple
glasses Apple spectacles Apple talks a
lot about augmented reality and I love
AR so much I love a are a lot more than
VR I do really really like VR but I like
augmented reality because doesn't take
me out of my world so I think that if
Apple is working on some really cool
goggles or glasses but they're gonna do
it to hopefully rights I've seen so many
fails over the years and I think if
anyone's going to actually do this and
actually make it work and be something
that we're gonna want to wear Apple's
gonna do it so I'm here cheering them on
for that but I don't think that they're
gonna see any announcements about that I
mean if we do I will be so shocked I
will probably fall over in my chair
maybe even hit the floor I probably
wanted the floor so it's really not a
lot of room in the same jobs theater
area so I probably will just say anyway
see like I'm just being dramatic anyway
those are just a few of the updates that
I've seen online again I'll put a link
the description if you want to check out
this article that I was getting most
this information from I am super excited
for the events and I can't wait to bring
you guys all along with me right now it
is like 11 p.m. it is past my bedtime
and I'm shooting this video the night
before I have to head to Cupertino so
I'm going to stop talking and I will see
you guys at the Apple event again make
sure you subscribe hit the bell follow
me on Twitter and Instagram and I will
see you guys soon I can't wait oh my
gosh so excited you guys have any
predictions feel free to tweet me
because I will be reading those on the
plane